[Applaudissements]
la parole est à Monsieur François
deasère merci monsieur le Président ma
question s'adresse au Premier ministre
et en son absence s'adressera à Madame
mari-elise Lebranchu tout à l'heure
madame ministre vous avez répondu à
notre collègues sur les budgets des
collectivités territoriales en disant
que l'effort demandé aux collectivités
territoriales était le même que celui
demandé à l'état vous savez les élus que
nous sommes regardons les budgets
qu'est-ce que l'on constate c'est que le
budget de l'État c'est 373 milliards
d'euros vous demandez un effort cette
année de 7,7 milliards d'euros
c'est-à-dire 2,06 % d'efforts et
qu'est-ce que vous demandez collectivité
territorial l'ensemble des dotation
versé aux collectivités territoriales la
célèbre dotation globale de
fonctionnement c'est 37 milliards
d'euros et vous nous demandez un effort
de 3 milliards 7 d'euros c'est-à-dire 10
% donc c'est facile à
plus deè élément madame la ministre vous
nous avez dit tout à l'heure vous nous
avez dit tout à l'heure la solution
c'est la péréquation madame la ministre
franchement venez avec la circulaire en
main et expliquez-nous la péréquation
c'est absolument
incompréhensible la conséquence c'est
quoi c'est que votre gouvernement se
rend responsable d'une faute historique
c'est
l'irresponsabilité raliser parce que les
maires aujourd'hui qui font l'objet
d'une péréquation très violente sont
obligés effectivement de baisser leur
investissement parfois même de couper
dans les budgets culturels ce qui me
paraît une erreur mais tout simplement
parce que le choc est tellement violent
et l'on ne sait même pas pourquoi on
nous prend de l'argent on ne sait pas
vers qui ça va on ne sait pas pour
quelle action alors madame la ministre
il nous faut de la transparence vraie
transparence pas de l'enfumage
dites-nous à quoi sert la péréquation
dans chacune des communes
bénéficiairesci la parole est à Monsieur
André Vallini secrétaire d'État chargé
de la réforme
territoriale merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Député vous avez cité
beaucoup de chiffres je vais en citer
quelquesuns à mon tour la dépense
publique globale dans notre pays est de
l'ordre de 1250 milliards d'euros la
dépense public local c'est 250 milliards
d'euros c'est 20 %. sur un plan
d'économie de 3 ans lancé par le
gouvernement pour réduire les déficits
de 50 milliards d'euros nous demandons
11 milliards d'euros au collectivité
locale c'est 20 %. c'est 20 %. 2è
élément monsieur le
député 3ard 670 millions d'euros
d'économie par an que nous demandons au
collectivité local c'est 1,6 % de leur
recette tot 1,6 % c'est beaucoup c'est
trop quand on est maire ce n'est pas
l'étranglement que vous décrivez 3è
élément 3è élément monsieur le député la
péréquation vous avez demandé à quoi ça
servait la péréquation ça sert à faire
jouer la solidarité entre les plus
riches et les moins favorisés entre les
communes les plus en difficulté et
celles qui ont des recettes c'est la
dotation de solidarité urbaine la
dotation de solidarité rurale c'est la
solidarité on aide plus ceux qui sont en
difficulté et on demande aussi aux
collectivités les plus favorisées de
participer à cet effort dernier élément
monsieur le député il y a un souci sur
l'investissement nous partageons
l'inquiétude des maires le Premier
ministre a réuni à plusieurs reprises
les représentants des associations avec
Marie-Lise le branchu nous les recevons
régulièrement chaque semaine nous avons
pris des mesures en matière de
compensation de la TVA de la dotation
d'équipement des territoires ruraux des
mesures nouvelles peuvent être annoncées
en juillet lors d'une nouvelle rencontre
avec la MF nous sommes très attentifs à
l'investissement public local qui
représente 70 % de l'investissement
public en France et nous sommes donc
très vigilants sur ce sujet